crystal's in anchorage hey crystal how
are you
hi good thanks so much for taking my
call sure what's up
um currently my husband and i are have
no debt except for
a little bit of a car payment and our
mortgage
uh we've got a steady income but we kind
of struggle
just getting by check to check and
wondering what is the best way to
kind of get out of that rut what's your
income
oh about six
uh about 72 000 a year okay how much
your house payment
1700. how much car payment
um about i do about 300
a month on it you would do what's your
car
payment you have a payment amount yeah
i i do about 300 a month on it i
i go a little bit extra okay but i mean
your car payment is actually if you
don't do
what's the actual payment 210. okay
that's what i'm asking
all right good okay so that's okay
because you're
the extra is a choice you know and
that's not a bad choice because we're
going to get your
car paid off that's going to be
something we're going to do here in a
minute but but uh we're going to put a
lot more than 300 on it but
um anyway all right so
you're not giving me any numbers here
that are
causing my brain to explode like you've
got major problems which means
that you're probably like most people
including me
when i first started this uh in that
by not having really good organization
with my money and
every detail out laid out it
the chaos eats these dollars for
breakfast
and so a written budget a detailed
budget
will make you feel like you've gotten a
raise because i'll give you an example
if you what how often you guys get paid
twice a month yeah okay so a take-home
pay check is how much
three thousand dollars okay so we got
six
thousand dollars minus house payment
minus car payment
is three is that that's two thousand
dollars yeah
yeah so i got four thousand dollars left
cause that feels kind of weird doesn't
it it does
like right this second you're asking
yourself i know i got water and
i know i got i got i know i've got
electricity and i know i've got food
uh and i know i got some insurance i got
to buy here and there uh but you're
starting to ask yourself where the flips
is money going and that's
kind of what i'm asking yeah so yeah you
got to get on a game plan and when you
get on a budget you are going to feel
like you got a raise
and crystal i'm going to tell you as i
started off on dave's plan
uh some almost 16 years ago that is
exactly what
was the thing that was the awakening for
me i was doing too much stupid in
grocery stores and in restaurants
and so getting down to the root of it
you taking a look get some bank
statements out go back and look at the
last three months and find out that
category where you're bleeding money
and it could be online shopping it could
be grocery stores it could be eating out
whatever it is you're going to do an
analysis you're going to see it but you
cannot manage money with a rear view
mirror
right you can't wait let's over and then
go wow that doesn't work
you have to tell it what to do before it
leaves
on paper on purpose before the month
begins
every single month and in agreement with
your spouse so they don't do something
else that's exactly right and i was just
going to say
with that when you find that trouble
spot go to the cash envelopes
on it i'm telling you having the budget
like dave's talking about beforehand and
then having the cash
i'm telling it's going to give you more
control and like dave said it's going to
feel like you gave yourself a raise
because guess what you did yeah jump on
every dollar
and start using the it's free to use
just every dollar.com download the app
and start using that budgeting app with
you and your husband and you
to start working on that tonight you're
going to feel like you got a raise
there's a reason you're leaving losing
you know
there's just no intentionality behind
the dollars and no one does by the way
you're not like you're not like horrible
nobody does that all right
you have sat down with people for many
many years what is the typical the area
of the budget that people
are absolutely lying about what is it
the one where you go this
isn't real eating out eating out yeah i
would agree i'd say eating out of the
grocery store
because with the stores we have now they
think they spend less at the grocery
store yeah they know they spend it a lot
at restaurants but when they find out
what they really spend they go oh my god
yep yeah yeah i remember i was sitting
in a financial peace group
leading small group one time years and
years ago and uh you know we're kind of
going around talking about the lesson
that night and we're like okay why
aren't why have you not been able to
fund retirement where it was an
investment lesson
one of the questions we're just talking
about you know why why didn't you feel
like you've been able to do retirement
and there's an old country boy sitting
in the thing and he goes
yeah we looked at it spending 1200
a month in restaurants i know where our
retirement's been going we've been
eating it
about died laughing but he's telling the
truth i've been eating it
that's it that i'm telling you that's
what a lot of people do with it
they eat they they eat their future yeah
and that's scary and you know what
that's something we can control because
what couldn't we
just tell you i love restaurants yeah a
lot of my
i've got good friends you and i have
good friends personal friends that we
share
they're world-class chefs that own
restaurants we go to their place
i love that kind of stuff i'm not
against restaurants but from a
budgeting standpoint when you're calling
me and saying i'm broke i have no money
i will tell you that ninety percent of
what you spend in the restaurant
the money is spent on entertainment ten
percent is your actual food cost
yeah so go home and make make some make
some makes
make some white beans and cornbread well
and and i'm going to tell you this even
throughout all this situation with the
pandemic of people being at home more
you know utilizing that found out what
they were spending they really did
because people were like what we've got
where about all this money where this
money come from that's right and it's
all it was you're not going all the time
all the time so be intentional be smart
and and again
starting to set some things cut it back
a little bit crystal you're not
different in that regard i don't know if
it's food that you're spending it on but
you will discover it
when you go back and look at the
statements like chris suggested and when
you start writing it down and try to
make it behave
hint for everyone is starting their new
budget this month
whatever you think you're spending at
the grocery store
you're wrong it's more than that
i agree and so if you think you're
spending 500
you better put 750 in there because
you're gonna find
that it's more you've you've been lying
to yourself so long
that you know i really do do that i've
had these people tell me these
ridiculous numbers we make it on fifty
dollars a month no you don't
you can't even no this is absolutely
ridiculous so
you know but but because here's the
thing that is a category that if you
under fund it you will go back and
either break your budget
or you'll have to go back and correct
your budget in the middle of the month
as you're learning how to budget your
first couple of months
if you'll go ahead and over fund it you
don't feel like you failed
you can always cut your food budget back
in future months that's a good call
for the first two to three months you're
doing your budget when you've never done
one in years
over fund your grocery store
budget because your category because
you're always
everyone spends more than they think
they're going they do
and you people that are super nerds and
you do the coupons and you've got all
these apps on your phone and all this
stuff
you still spend more than you think you
have because we
there's something about denial at the
grocery store that we didn't we're in
denial about what we spent no that's a
good point and at the reset event if you
haven't watched that you need to go
check it out
i gave three tips which is make a
grocery list
only buy what's on the list and stick to
the dollar amount you said you're going
to spend i'll give you a fourth one
don't go grocery shopping when you're
hungry
truth big truth as if i have ever done
anything yes but there you go those
burritos i bought from sam's weren't
that good when i got him home well you
bought two
270 yeah i know i was hungry dave i was
real hungry